[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor welcome friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
what has two eyes three hearts
nine brains and blue blood you might be
thinking it's an alien but it's actually
an octopus octopus are some of the most
unique and highly intelligent creatures
in the sea found in oceans throughout
the world they can range in size from
one inch to the largest individual on
record which was a Pacific octopus which
weighed in at 600 pounds and was 30 feet
across they have one brain for their
head and then a separate brain for each
of their arms that can be independently
manipulated without input from the
primary brain if they lose one of their
arms they can generally grow it back
octopus also have blue blood thanks to
the copper rich protein in their
bloodstream that makes it more efficient
for transporting oxygen in cold ocean
environments all octopus have venom but
only the blue ringed octopus is deadly
to humans
in addition these crafty creatures have
the amazing ability to change their skin
color and even the texture to camouflage
their appearance using pixelated colors
texture and arm contortions in a
fraction of a second these body artists
can instantly vanish into the seascape
some octopus can even morph their shape
and color to appear like other creatures
is a lobster snakes lionfish and they
are incredibly flexible they can squeeze
through any hole if it's big enough to
accommodate their beak if all of these
methods fail to confuse and evade their
predators then they release an inky
black cloud as they jet away you know
the Bible talks about a fallen angel
that's even more versatile and crafty
than an octopus stay with his friends
were going to learn more on this edition
of Bible answers live you're listening
to Bible answers live welcome
listening friends is a Bible answers
live and we'd invite you to call in if
you have any Bible question we have
lines open and a call that number is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven that's 800 God says if you
want the acronym 800 for six three seven
two nine seven callin now with your
Bible question and great chance so get
it on tonight's program
we're also streaming what is happening
here in the studio at the amazing facts
Facebook page as well as the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page and that's me
Doug Batchelor Pastor John Ross is off
tonight
but we're going to go to the phones in
just a minute after we pray together
loving lord thank you for your word that
is the way the truth and the life that
sets us free and we pray now Lord that
these words that are spirit and life
will come to life as we study it on this
broadcast bless all who call in and the
answer is given we pray in Jesus name
Amen
well I'm still amazed by the octopus
I've been scuba diving Karen and I are
certified and and more than once we've
been up close and personal in Hawaii a
couple of years ago one of our divers
that was with us caught a little octopus
and put it on his hand it is wrapped
around his finger it was rather friendly
I was surprised but they're in there
it's almost like they're from another
planet there's such interesting
creatures they say they're related to
molluscs but they got big eyes and a
brain that a typical mollusk doesn't
have and and they can open jars they can
take their section cups and take two
pieces of coconut shell that are on the
sea floor and pull them together to
protect themselves like shields from
their enemy they have the ability to
learn very quickly people in and marine
aquariums that study the octopus that
they come to recognize individuals and
they can solve puzzles and they're just
very clever little creatures and I've
seen the before morph into coral they'll
be going along and suddenly turn from
red to brown and change colors in just a
fraction of a second so they disappear
that could never evolve but you know
they're they're crafty creative ability
makes me think of another creature he is
a creature he is not a creator and his
name is the devil and he has the ability
to morph as well
you can read about it all the sin in the
world today started when the devil he
actually possessed a serpent in Genesis
chapter 3 now the serpent was more
cunning than any beast of the field
which the Lord God had made and he said
to the woman has God said so now the
devil is speaking through this serpent
jesus warned us in Matthew 7 beware of
false prophets who come to you in
sheep's clothing but inwardly they are
ravening the wolves so the devil can
morph into a sheep or make you think
he's a sheep but he's still a wolf and
even in 2nd Corinthians 11:14 Paul tells
us there and no wonder for Satan himself
can transform himself into an angel of
light when Jesus was tempted by the
devil in the wilderness I seriously
doubt that the devil appeared looking
like some diabolical monster and then
started to try to tempt Jesus who would
be fooled by that I think the devil
appeared as an angel of light pretending
he was sent by the father and then he
began to try to tempt and
use Jesus now we don't need to be fooled
by the devil's tricks and counterfeits
and we've got a book that why I don't
know if we've offered this in some time
do you like a free copy of our book it's
called Satan's confusing counterfeits
it's a classic written by Joe Cruz
that'll help you be more aware of what
the devil's some of his confusing tricks
are Satan's confusing counterfeits if
you want a free copy here is the
resource number you dial 800 eight three
five six seven four seven that's if you
want to either a chaplain to pray with
you or if you want to one of the free
resources one more time 808 three five
six seven four seven if you have a Bible
question call us 800 four six three
seven two nine seven and with that we
had some lines open give us a call we're
gonna talk to Patrick in Toronto Canada
Patrick you're on the line with Bible
answers live i pastor Doug how are you
I'm doing great how are you I'm good I
have actually have few questions but I'm
gonna I'm gonna go pretty quick the
earth kept Sabbath I just want to find
out how long there's kick kep Stuyvesant
oh it was changed and told people
observed Sunday well the Sabbath was
instituted in Genesis chapter 2 on the
seventh day you know God made the world
in six days but we have a seven-day week
because I God added one more day because
life is nothing without love and he had
an another day for quality time and love
relationships between man and his
creator so the Sabbath started then and
the Sabbath has never ended you know
every seventh day has been God's Sabbath
from creation till now his people
through time have often neglected her
forgot it or not kept it correctly but
the Sabbath hasn't stopped now during
the dark ages you so you're wondering
when did they start changing it so that
many Christians were keeping the first
day instead of the seventh day yeah when
did they I believe
I heard you mentioned before that the
earth kept that the people kept Sabbath
for I don't remember how many years I
don't know if it was over a thousand
years and and I'm just trying to find
out when it is when did they start
observing well our first of all after
I'll do my best to answer your question
and then there's a couple of books I can
offer you for a free book and even a
website that'll answer that in more
detail but when the children of Israel
were in Egypt they began to neglect the
Sabbath and the Pharaoh was trying to
get him to work seven days without rest
making bricks without straw one of the
first things God does as he brings them
well the Pharaoh got upset with Moses he
said you're making the people rest and
that word rest is Shabbat same exact
word he said you're making the people
Shabbat I'm going to double their
workload then when they get out of the
wilderness before they ever get to Mount
Sinai God gives him bread six days a
week and he said gather twice as much on
the sixth day because there'll be none
on the seventh day that's the Sabbath so
you know the Lord was saying you've been
neglecting the Sabbath before he ever
reiterates it at Mount Sinai then during
the Christian dispensation after the
disciples began to go everywhere
preaching the early church all kept the
Sabbath it wasn't until maybe two and a
half three hundred years after Christ
when in order to reach the pagans with
the conversion of Constantine they said
well let's keep two days so that we can
you know start bringing the pagans in
and then gradually they began to neglect
the seventh day and so many Romans came
into the church they started keeping the
first day and it happened over a period
of a couple of hundred years so and then
you know but they're they're been
faithful people all the way from the
time of Adam to the present that have
kept the Sabbath there's a website I
recommend it's got a lot of historical
documentation on this and different
scholars that have talked about it it's
called Sabbath truth calm Sabbath truth
calm and I hope that'll help a little
Patrick I know you have another question
but I see the phones are lighting up and
I want to be fair to our other callers
so I call back again and we'll deal with
some of the other questions thank you
saying we're talking to Zane you're on
the
I would Bible answers live since this
year I am wanted to grow closer to God
and that was something everyone did real
close to your phones and your your voice
is drifting off a little bit so get real
close to your phone um so you don't
probably grow closer to the Lord yes
because I've been going to a lot of
struggles and stuff my family's been
suffering you know even close friends of
mine and I've been trying to see the
light and everything but it just feels
like everything's just being hard and I
worry that I'm not going to be able to
withstand all this stuff going on
all right well prayer of course is very
powerful I mean let me give you the
secret ingredients for spiritual growth
are three things to be healthy
physically you of course need food you
need exercise you need to breathe you
need water to be healthy spiritually you
need food and water I kind of there in
one category that's the living water and
the bread of life you need to be reading
the word praying for God's Spirit the
most important thing that we need to ask
for is the Holy Spirit now I know you're
going through some trials but keep this
in mind God promises in 1st Corinthians
chapter 10 the Lord will not allow you
to be tempted above what you're able to
bear so he'll never put a burden on you
that you're not able to bear with his
strength the other thing is share your
faith when you're going through a hard
time
it really helps even if you're
struggling to think about others even on
the cross Jesus reached out to save a
thief next to him he stopped thinking
about his own suffering on the cross and
thought about the thief that was
perishing next to him so don't don't
become so a focused inward on some of
the challenges you're having that you
you know you can become absorbed with it
an extra so you got exercise you need to
eat you need to breathe and that's
prayer so if you're doing those things
you'll grow in the sanctuary there were
three pieces of furniture in the holy
place the light that's letting your
light shine that's the exercise
witnessing sharing your faith you've got
the bread that's the Word of God man
doesn't live by bread alone we need to
read our Bibles every day and then you
had the altar of incense revelation says
that altar is a symbol of the prayers of
the saints so we need to pray now you
continue to do those things I've never
met a backsliding Christian that was
actively involved in prayer Bible study
and sharing their faith and we've got a
book we'll be happy to send you a free
copy zine and it's talking about how
teach us to pray it's about the prayer
life in the devotional life and that
will strengthen your faith I promise and
you will grow thank you so much for your
question gonna talk next to you Frank
calling from New York you Frank you're
on the air with Bible answers live I
call this evening your to your show
because I was just wondering I read
about these places that are in the Bible
or names and prophets that are in the
Bible and and I compared them to street
names here in New York City in the
borough and County of the Bronx called
Trinity place then there's another place
in Manhattan in the county of New York
called st. Mark's Place and then I see
another place called decal Avenue in
Brooklyn and I just was wondering pastor
Doug why do they name streets after
figures and biblical persons in the
Bible you know something that goes way
back my guess is if rank that you know
at one point there was churches on some
of those streets and you know some of
the street names we've got go back a
couple hundred years if you're on the
East Coast and there may have been a a
church called Trinity Church and the
street ended up becoming st. mark Street
for the
Saint Mark's Church or Trinity Church or
some of these were probably Episcopal or
Anglican churches that came from England
and some may be the Catholic churches
that were established that's my guess I
don't know every street the history
might be a little different you might
find a street named Abraham several
places in North America and it could be
a Bible character and it could be an
individual so I'm not sure that but I
have seen streets before that were named
after churches because it was the
prominent building on the street and the
street just took up that name all right
well thank you very much you Frank we're
gonna talk with Dee idea Colleen hi
you're on the air with Bible answers
live yes can you hear me loud and clear
good how can you how can we help you yes
my question I'm trying to learn how to
keep the Sabbath okay like my family um
they're having like uh like uh like say
a baby shower or what birthday or
something on the Sabbath so am I not can
I just sit there or they gonna say well
wow yeah that I know that can make it a
little difficult well you know there's
different kinds of occasions and you
know if a person is I've been to
weddings before wedding this you know
biblical si can be a sacred occasion
baby well a baby shower you know and
sometimes what you need to do is you
don't want to neglect your worship it
depends on when you know when this might
be happening but you do your best to go
and you know try to support the family
without sacrificing your convictions if
you can do that sometimes it depends
from one family occasion to another and
one family to another if you know you've
got a family occasion and your family is
going to be drinking and they're gonna
have the football game going it's really
gonna be hard for you to be in the mind
of of the Sabbath during those occasions
but then you know they're they might be
Christians having a baby shower
it's gonna be a spiritual occasion so it
you're gonna have to be the judge of
that but you don't want to put God
second place to friends and family
obedience to the Lord is going to always
be the most important thing and the same
time you know God wants you to show your
love for the for your family Jesus he
went to weddings and he believed in
coming to social occasions to celebrate
events in life but yeah you just pray
for wisdom I don't want to be the Holy
Spirit and just in on a case by case
basis depending on the circumstances
some might be something that you could
do in good conscience and still keep the
Sabbath and some might not so I hope
that helps a little we do have a book
that we can send you a copy if you ask
for it D and it's called how to keep the
Sabbath and there's a bunch of
principles in there that I think will
help you with that if you call the
resource number 800 eight three five six
seven four seven D will send you a free
copy of that how to keep the Sabbath 808
three five six seven four seven and
thank you for your call gonna go next
and talk with Albert calling from
Montana Albert you're on the air with
Bible answers live do you think pastor
Doug how are you doing doing well thank
you
any ways that you a nice question I have
for you pastor is uh could you define to
us what our act - it'd be a whole
chapter were you you want me to read the
whole chapter just say what it's about
or just yeah just giving a brief summary
on what it is well acts 2 is when God
pours out the Holy Spirit following
there 10 days of Prayer in the upper
room and it contains Peters four sermons
so it's you know probably 47 48 verses
yes it is it's it's 47 verses but were
you was there something specific in the
chapter you're wondering about er yes I
believe the
hostels were trying to are trying to
colonize people or how did could you
could give me a better summary of of
your interpretation towards that
chapters yeah well you can read where
Jesus said that after Jesus ascended to
heaven he said wait in Jerusalem for the
Holy Spirit and the Holy Spirit will
come upon you and you will be my
witnesses so Christ appeared among the
disciples for forty days then he
ascended to heaven while they were
watching said wait for the Holy Spirit
it will come and they prayed in the
upper room they are in Jerusalem for ten
days chapter two begins the Holy Spirit
is poured out mighty power the disciples
are given the ability to speak in other
languages it happens during the Jewish
festival of Pentecost where Jews from
around the Roman Empire have come to
worship they speak other languages so
they hear the disciples speaking in
their native tongues talking about
Christ and Peter preaches a powerful
sermon explaining that Jesus is the
Messiah and at the end of his sermon
they're so convicted they say men and
brethren what shall we do Peter says
repent and you'll receive be baptized
you'll receive the gift of the Holy
Spirit and then 3,000 are baptized and
the church really took off at that point
it went from 12 and 120 in the Upper
Room mm and you reading few chapters
later another 5,000 are baptized so um
you know the main theme of that chapter
is dealing with the Holy Spirit and if
you like I'd be happy to send you the
art book that I wrote called our
greatest need the Holy Spirit and all
you've got to do is ask for that Albert
and call the number to call is 808 three
five six seven four seven ask for Pastor
Doug's book telling you're listening to
Bible answers live on our greatest need
the Holy Spirit and I think you'll be
blessed by that okay okay let me see you
we got next lined up here Beverly is
calling from California
Beverly you're on the air with Bible
answers
thank you for taking my call yeah you
know I've been thinking and wondering
about when is our name actually put into
the book of life I think that when a
person accepts Jesus and they repent of
their sins and confess their sins their
names are entered into the book of life
even you see Moses talked about those
that were in God's book and he acted
like while he was alive his name was in
God's book and so the book of life
people can have their names written in
it while they're alive
you read that's what I thought yeah and
in Revelation I think further proof for
that is in Revelation Jesus sends a
message through the Apostle John to the
churches and he tells one of the
churches I'm trying to remember which
one it is right now that you know except
they repent he will take their name out
of the book so the names must already be
in the book if he's threatening to take
their names out of the book so um yeah
well see that's what I thought but then
I kept thinking well maybe they're put
in when we're born that everyone's name
is put into the book of life and then if
you don't accept Christ or if you don't
be you're not converted or you're not
baptized and the different things then
your name would be removed so you would
not have eternal life no I think your
name you see we don't have eternal life
by virtue of being born we're born with
our fallen nature the baby does doesn't
it well a baby is not guilty of sin so
if a child dies before the age of
accountability then you know they're
gonna be saved but that doesn't mean
their names are entered in the book of
life by virtue of a choice of accepting
Christ I think that's a separate issue
so once a person reaches the age of
accountability and they've sinned we
want the our sins forgiven and God
enters our name in the book of life and
that happens I believe at the time of
conversion that's why they call it you
know Jesus said unless you are born
again it's the second birth that
qualifies us not the first birth
and birth and born again that qualifies
us for having our names in God's book
thank you very much for that Beverly I'm
going to see if I can take another call
before we go to our break here all right
is it Gardner four in New York you've
got a question yes Luke 12 Luke 12:47
248 talks about people being beaten with
many stripes if you knew to do good and
you didn't do the Lord's will many
stripes and if you didn't know what you
still did some things that deserve
stripes that you'll be beaten with less
stripes
so looking at this at the first class it
sounds like that people being occurs as
the salvation process either reward or
punishment I don't think that's what
that means so what the ghost strikes
beam in those two scriptures please yeah
when the word stripes is sort of a
general term that was used in Bible
times for punishment and Jesus does say
everyone is rewarded according to his
works and there are varying degrees of
works and their varying degrees of
rewards in Roman times if you were bad
they had different levels of whipping
that would happen you know if it was a
minor offense you might get whipped
twice if the most serious would be I
think 39 lashes no one was allowed to be
wit more than that because it might kill
them and so when Jesus talks about few
stripes and many stripes he's talking
about degrees of punishment based upon
bad behavior and he said if a person
knows his masters will and he ignores it
he's going to be dealt with more
severely than if a person sinned kind of
against his own conscience but he didn't
really know and I think Jesus is just
saying you know they're varying degrees
of punishment and reward in in the
kingdom does that make sense yeah I
didn't want to say you know we don't
think of different degrees of punishment
now we do think of different degrees of
reward in heaven that we all heard that
but we don't think that that there's
going to be different levels of torture
in hell
well the Jesus said that to whom much is
given much is required and he that is
faithful in least is also faithful much
and then you read in Revelation behold
he comes in the cloud if his reward is
with them to give to every man according
to his works
so there are varying degrees of
punishment now see we don't believe we
believe there is a lake of fire and
people are punished according to what
they deserve we don't believe that lake
of fire burns for billions and zillions
of years endlessly we think that
ultimately the wicked depending on you
know what they've done they're gonna be
burn up Bible says in Malachi chapter 4
the wicked are burned up they're
consumed you can read and it says it's
the second death they are devoured they
perish into smoke they consume away
their name will not be anymore so the
language in the Bible is you either have
everlasting life
or you perish but before the wicked
perish they are punished according to
what everyone deserves
don't go away friends we're coming back
you want more information on that
question you want to go to hell truth
Calm health truth calm more information
on the subject of Hell and we're gonna
take a brief break be back with more
Bible questions stand by
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers seek his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 having a faith crisis
more of a denomination crisis I know
there's different denominations who may
say they are the true church or their
restored Church is there a true Church
and can you maybe suggest a book or
article to read yeah well first of all
we'll send you a book if you call the
number it's called search for the true
church there are criteria that are given
in the Bible how do you find that church
and so when you follow the criteria it
narrows the field very quickly you can
read in revelation 17 about this false
mother of harlots she's called Babylon
and it describes that she's been
unfaithful she becomes sort of like a
political institution and it says she
has daughters that came out of her so
there's no question you know there's
hundreds of different denominations that
call themselves Christian many say they
use the Bible in various degrees some
say they use the Bible plus the writings
of somebody else and you know you just
want to go by what does the Bible say
the criteria is if you're searching
promises seek and you'll find now will
people be saved for many different
churches I believe absolutely
God looks on the heart
we got to be careful not to judge is
there a church that is closer to the
Bible than others obviously there must
be and so you you know you want to be
there so I think there's a movement that
is also foretold in in prophecy that you
can trace now let me just remind you in
the Old Testament did God have a people
was there a nation that he was
specifically working with yeah nation of
Israel does that mean that they were all
good people and they always did things
right
no there are a lot of ups and downs but
he delivered to them the Oracles of
truth that's a quote from Paul God gave
the Jewish nation his word they had the
law they had the writings of Moses they
had the prophets they had the truth even
Jesus said to the Samaritan woman she
wanted to argue with Jesus which
mountain it's like saying which church
which mountain are we to worship on
Jerusalem or Gerizim and Jesus said
salvation is of the Jews he was very
clear God had given the word to the
Jewish nation well now the Jews have
been scattered around the world and
Christ came and the church grew but is
there a particular movement that God is
working with today take a look add to
that book called search for the true
church we'll send you a free copy just
call 800 and I think this will really
help you Toni 808 three five six seven
four seven that is the resource number
you know friends we've thought for years
about another way to do it but we need
two numbers we need the number for
questions we need the number for
resources because they're really going
to two different places the one is
specifically set up to pray with people
and to send out the resources and the
people here in this studio are all wired
to take and screen the calls and
engineer the program so that's why we
give out two numbers but if you want the
the free resources 808 three five six
seven four seven and with that let me
see we're going to talk to Henry in the
Bronx Henry you're on the air with Bible
answers live yeah pastor but the New
Year to you thank you so much as there
is in the Bible and when Christ ascended
having big Nate Peter the first pope of
rome no yeah sometimes the the Catholic
Church will say that God had elected
Peter to be the first pope nothing could
be further from the truth and they talk
about where Jesus said on this rock I
will build my church see Jesus says to
Peter you are Peter and the word Peter
there means Petros
it means Rock when you could pick up and
throw rock you'd put in a sling but he
says on this Petra the Petra is a rock
of immense proportions like the Rock of
Gibraltar and the great rock that Jesus
is alluding to is what Peter had said
that Christ Jesus was the Christ on that
statement he was going to build his
church the church was not being built on
Peter because within a few minutes of
Jesus saying that he turns to Peter and
he said Peter Satan get behind me
he calls Peter Satan let's hope Jesus
isn't building his church on the Apostle
Peter because Peter kind of went up and
down a few times and it's the truth of
his word that Christ has built the
church on Peter is not the first Pope
one thing we know right away Peter was
married popes are not married and so
this idea of papal succession is not
taught in the Bible hopefully that helps
a little bit Henry and you would enjoy
our DVD on Revelation the bride the
beast in Babylon you call 883 five six
seven four seven ask for the DVD the
bride the Beast and Babylon you know
anyone out there that wants that it
isn't very long before our DVDs find
their way to youtube and I think you
could probably see that on YouTube and
our new DVD that we're advertising now
called kingdoms in time about prophecy
that can be also downloaded from Amazon
Prime Amazon thought it was so good and
and pure flix they're carried by both of
those online and movie services
alright talking to Ghana Africa Emanuel
welcome you're on the line good morning
morning for you and how can we help you
today
morning is about Holy Spirit in fact
after 11411 it is when the Holy Spirit
came upon the Apostles or the disciples
they were speaking in tongues and then
some men from Jerusalem they heard a
song in different languages and in APA
language but when I read first
Corinthians are supporting you
it is the song is an easy to vote no one
understands it so I just want to know if
we should understand all songs oh I mean
yeah alright let me see what I can do
now that's a question I'm especially
interested in because when I first
became a Christian most of my friends I
fell oh and worship with they
practice speaking in tongues and I was
very mystified and confused by this I'd
read it in the Bible and I had always
you know I read the Bible by myself
pretty much up in a cave and when I came
across this subject I never got out of
it what they were getting Jesus says in
mark 16 that you're to go into all the
world and he said you will speak with
other tongues the word tongues there
simply means languages of the day of
Pentecost there was a brilliant timing
God gave the Apostles the ability to
supernaturally speak other languages
that they had not formally known or
studied for the purpose of spreading the
gospel to these visiting Jews from all
over the Roman Empire and it mentioned
16 different language groups in Acts
chapter 2 they then are converted they
take the gospel back to their countries
and they preach in first Corinthians 14
the Church of Corinth is the only church
that Paul writes to and talks about
tongues Paul never mentions tongues in
any of his other letters just first
Corinthians the Corinthian church was
made up of largely slaves that lived in
corinth from the roman empire they spoke
many different languages are probably
from many different countries and their
services were lots of translation people
getting up praying and speaking in
languages the word tongues just means
languages the others did not understand
and Paul is saying there first
Corinthians 14 he who speaks in an
unknown language
doesn't speak to men but to God no one
understands him in the spirit II
speaking mysteries in other words he's
might be spirit filled but what he says
is mysterious to everyone else and you
know if I should say so tick mark Lucia
well that's pon a pan from Micronesia
good evening everybody most people don't
know that or if I were to say on Ivana
Kamali vanakkam see I've been to these
countries and I learned how to say good
evening
that's Tamil good evening friends it's
not helping anybody if I speak in these
tongues that nobody knows
so if Paul is simply saying let there be
an interpreter if you're gonna be
speaking in a tongue others don't
understand people take this chapter and
totally confuse it hey I tell you what
Emmanuel I know you're in Africa so we
can't mail it to you but you go to the
amazing fax website and you can freely
download a book I've written called
understanding tongues it goes completely
through the subject of tongues it's a
quick read but it's very thorough
understanding tongues and it uses all
these verses in first Corinthians anyone
out there if you're confused about
what's going on in some of these
churches with speaking in tongues I
believe in all the gifts of the Spirit I
believe in the gift of tongues I believe
it has been missed taught by many and
you read the book you see if it sticks
to the scripture that's the main test
one more time if you want a free copy
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and that's the book
understanding tongues or download it at
amazing facts dot o-r-g amazing facts
idato RG Thank You Emmanuel for your
your faithful call and let me see here
we're gonna go to go and go to Joseph
calling from Pennsylvania Joseph you're
on the air with Bible answers live
good evening pastor evening thank you
patience no problem I I want to know if
Jesus in his experience on earth ever
had any ability to sympathize with us
when we feel guilt we know from Hebrews
14 that he that we have Jesus as our
high priest who's able signifies that
our weakness because he was tempted and
all the things that we were but we go
ahead and sin where Jesus never did
so we that we repented and are forgiven
sometimes will have feelings of guilt
and say to ourselves how could either
you know what was I thinking but is
there anything in Jesus's earthly
experience that would allow him to
sympathize with our weaknesses when it
comes to guilt great question
first let me say that part of wisdom is
that you can empathize with a person and
you can empathize with their mistakes
without having to make their mistakes
you know they say wisdom is learning
from other people's mistakes and I might
sympathize with a friend who lost his
wife and to the best of my ability
I will empathize means you feel what
they're feeling that comes from the word
pathos I've never lost my wife but I can
try to empathize with them now Jesus
though when it comes to feeling guilty
in a sense he does know how we feel
because on the cross he took our sins he
felt the shame and the separation that
we feel from the Father
matter of fact that for him was probably
the most painful thing as Christ felt
the shame he felt the the sin in the
darkness the separation the guilt
because he took all of ours willingly
and so I think that yeah he really did
experience that and that is a great
question Joseph Bible says that he was
tempted in all points and then one more
thing to remember because God is
all-knowing one of the characteristics
of God is he's omniscient he's
all-knowing that means he knows
everything you think he knows every
feeling you feel every sensation you
feel Jesus did not need to live on earth
to know how we feel he may have needed
to do it in part so we would know that
he knows it's not that God doesn't know
it so that we'll know he knows how how
we feel and but God knows everything so
he is perfect at empathizing with our
suffering good question Thank You Joseph
oh let's see here talk to Allison
Placerville I'm assuming California
Alyce you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi pastor Doug I have a
question that comes from John 14 okay
the chapter is talking
about the Holy Spirit and about being
the comforter and my question is this
miss might be something that can't be
answered until we're in heaven but I got
to ask I've gotten really curious about
ok I'm fairly familiar about what the
the role of the Holy Spirit is while
we're here on earth but what I'm kind of
curious about is what will get the role
of the Holy Spirit in heaven and a New
Jerusalem
well you know the role of the Father Son
and spirit for us will be different
right now all three members of the
Godhead are involved in our Redemption
they will not be involved in that in
heaven but right Jesus
when he took on our form he did take on
a physical body he still has that in the
resurrection the Holy Spirit wherever we
go through the universe the presence of
God will be with us through God the
spirit and Jesus said the spirit is not
only with us he said he will be in you
so one of the ways that we know God is
by God in us you know Paul always talks
about Christ in you so Jesus is in us
through the Holy Spirit that's why he
said it's expedient that I go to the
Father because you know I can only be
with some of you now physically but when
I go to the Father then I can be in you
through God the spirit wherever you go
that's why Christ going to heaven he
said I am with you wherever you go so
even in the universe I plan on doing
some serious traveling when I get to
heaven finding out what God's got out
there and God is going to be with me
wherever I go through the spirit I see
ok so yeah but one of the one of the
roles of the Holy Spirit is of course
the convict of sin we won't have that in
happen so you know Jesus of course is
our Redeemer and we're not going to need
further redemption in that respect you
know I have a book I'll be happy to send
your free copy Alice and it's called the
Holy Spirit our need and it talks a
little bit about I think even in the end
of the book I talk about the role of the
Holy Spirit in heaven heaven it's been a
few years since I wrote it I'm trying to
remember but we'll send you a free copy
call 808 3:5
six seven four seven and ask for that
book the Holy Spirit the need and with
that we're gonna go to another call
let's see talking next with Chris
calling from Georgia Chris you're on the
air with Bible answers live um hello
pastor Doug thank you so much for taking
my call my question yes thank you my
question is how do you go about praying
for for a potential spouse because
sometimes I feel guilty praying for
somebody that I has specifically in mind
versus praying for God's will and simply
waiting um so yeah that's my calling and
thank you so much for again thank you my
call that's a good question you know one
of the most important decisions in life
this is a three or four very important
events in life you know one is your
birth most people don't have much choice
in that another one is your death most
people don't have a big choice in that I
want us to follow Jesus in baptism we do
have a choice in that and one of the
other really big decisions is your life
partner assuming you do get married not
everyone does having the right person
can it can be a life and death decision
quite literally that person can help
encourage you on the path to God or away
and you know Jesus said you don't want
to be unequally yoked so praying for
that right person is very important now
you may have someone specific in mind
and you think boy I sure feel attracted
to them Lord I hope that that person
will say yes and that they're the one
well you know you can tell god what you
would like but then you always want to
submit to him and say Lord if this is
your will because though I may be
attracted if this is not the person that
you have in mind I want who you have in
mind that will always be better in the
long run
to ask for what God's will is so you
know Chris I have a book I've written on
marriage divorce and remarriage and even
if you're not involved in divorce or
remarriage it does talk about principles
of marriage and I think you'll enjoy
that and the price is right we'll send
you a free copy if you'd like it
how's that sound that's how amazing
thank you so much
alrighty thanks so much and we'll
for you that you find the right person
that book is again marriage divorce and
remarriage and it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
not the price the book is free that's
the phone number 883 five six seven four
seven and we'll send you that book
alright we've got time for a couple more
callers ken in Alabama I think Ken
you're on the air with Bible answers
live yes how are you doing good are you
going down the road yes I am all right
well let me take your question I'll do
my best
I might have to answer put you on hold
my question is can you lose your
salvation and once you've received
Christ as your Savior all right very
good question
and that's one of the big debates in the
Christian world is once you've accepted
Christ can you lose your salvation well
there are verses that promise that if we
come to the Lord he'll never forsake us
he will never let go of us but that can
be misunderstood to think that we then
lose our freedom to let go of him
there's several examples in the Bible of
people who did come to Christ but then
they they fell away people who were even
spirit-filled but then they became proud
over the years and grieved away the Holy
Spirit and Paul learns about that he
said you know there are people who
preach to others he Paul said even he
after coming to Christ and accepting
Christ and being spirit filled is that
lest I preach to others but I am a
castaway and so he said you know I have
to submit myself I die daily there's an
ongoing struggle in the Christian life
to maintain that relationship I think
it's reckless it's a little dangerous
when some Christians are taught once you
say a prayer and you accept Jesus and
you're sincere then regardless of what
you do in your life you cannot lose your
salvation you know I think you can have
assurance in your relationship with the
Lord but you cannot be neglectful and
can't be presumptuous and you can't be
reckless because God is clear that
people like King Saul chosen by the Lord
filled by the God's Spirit but he became
proud and then rebellious and he ended
up grieving away the whole East
and falling on his sword Judas was along
with the other apostles he went out
casting out Devils and doing miracles
but he was greedy and covetous and he
would not repent of his sins even when
Jesus washed his feet and jesus' he went
out into darkness it's a Satan entered
him Paul talks about a dog that goes to
his own vomit and a pig that was washed
returned to wallowing in the mire and so
there are some people that turn away and
Jesus wrote to the church in the book of
Revelation chapter 2 and 3 that if they
did not repent
these are churches Christians he said I
will remove your candlestick out of its
place and our names can be taken from
the book of life so you know there's
many examples that say you must continue
to abide in Christ if we do not abide in
Christ John 15 then you know we can
pluck be plucked up and gathered the the
cuttings are gathered and burned so you
know we have a book can a saved man be
lost I will send you a free copy of that
book if you like call 808 three five six
seven four seven can a saved man be lost
got a lot of scripture in it friends and
I think you'll find it a very powerful
middle-of-the-road explanation how you
can have assurance but you can lose your
salvation if you are playing Russian
roulette with eternity and you don't
want to do that alright who is next here
got time for one or two more let's see
that would be Anthony New York you're on
the air with Bible answers live hi thank
you for taking my call absolutely um my
question has to do with Luke chapter 17
verse 4 basically where it says that if
your brother if somebody trespassed
against you seven times in a day seven
times and he comes back seven times in a
day asking for forgiveness
you shall forgive him yeah I've heard
someone interpret that to mean that you
are
or you know give them the liberty to say
that I will only forgive someone if they
come to me and ask forgiveness but I
don't have to extend forgiveness so I
don't have to forgive and just let
things go even if somebody doesn't come
ask for forgiveness I just wanted to
know how does that relate to you know
what the Bible says if you do not
forgive men their trip their trespasses
I will not forgive you give us our debts
as we forgive you know and writers well
there's a couple of the great question
there's a few different aspects of
forgiveness you know if if someone comes
to you if they've offended you and they
come to you and say you know I'm sorry I
you may have cut off the relationship
when they offended you because you
thought this is toxic but then they come
to you and they say you know I'm sorry
and you see that there's repentance
there you say all right let's see if we
can restore this relationship if someone
you know they're working for me and they
shoplift and they get caught and they
say I'm sorry I'll say you're forgiven
but I'm not gonna hire them again if
they're shoplifters you know so God is
not saying that you need to continue to
let people abuse you because that's not
good for them right but I do think that
when you forgive someone you're helping
yourself in other words it's it can make
a person bitter inside who was it that
said unforgiveness is a poison it's an
acid that corrodes the container that
holds it so if we've got bitterness and
unforgiveness in our hearts it burns us
up so you always want to forgive you
don't want to have resentment and
bitterness for anybody even if they
don't ask you I know people I preach
about forgiveness they come to me and
they say you know my my dad beat me when
I was a kid not been mad at him for
years and he's dead he's never asked me
for forgiveness what do I do I said well
you got to forgive him for your sake you
just get a serie he was a sinner lord
have mercy on him and just let it go but
you don't want to spend your life being
bitter and angry at somebody because
that'll hurt you
so there's different aspects of
forgiveness this is making sense yes it
does
yeah but and I do think it's important
like if I offend somebody and I want
forgiveness I go to that person because
I think that's part of the process God
knows when we sin but yet we're told to
confess to him why he knows because it
does something for us so yeah I think
confession is very important and of
course repentance needs to go with that
but thank you very much Anthony I do
have a sermon online I think you'll find
beneficiary and it's called seventy
times seven you just type in type into
YouTube or the amazing facts Channel
seventy times seven Doug Batchelor and
I've got a study there on forgiveness I
think that you'll find encouraging you
know I'm looking at the clock and then
I'm looking at the phone calls and I see
Jay Deborah Joshua I am so sorry I did
not get to your calls tonight I hope you
give us another chance
it would be sort of an insult to take
your call in the last few minutes that
we've got but listening friends I hope
you will also plan on tuning it again
next week in the few moments that remain
I'd like to remind you that the only
reason that we are on the air is because
people just like you who hear the
program if you'll move by the Holy
Spirit to say you know I want to give to
help support this basic simple direct
Bible teaching and we try to do the most
direct teaching you can do where people
ask specific questions we open our
Bibles and we give them answers to help
people grow in the faith if you've been
blessed and you enjoy the program some
listen for years but they never do
anything to help us stay on the air we
need to hear from you just go to amazing
facts dot o-r-g tell us if you've been
encouraged by the program we'd love to
hear from you amazing facts dot o-r-g
god bless we'll study again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California terror attacks
natural disasters political instability
and global economic meltdown these are
the images people generally associate
with the tribulation and the day of the
Lord but did you know the Bible speaks
about another day of the Lord just
before the great Judgment Day amazingly
imprinted on the very fabric of time
itself is a 24-hour period called the
Sabbath that was meant to forever be a
time of restoration for every human
being a day the entire world is largely
forgotten you'll be surprised to learn
how this special day of the Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called
the last day of prophecy to order call
800 538 7 to 75 or visit a book store
calm written by the hand of God and
spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
com DG no amazing facts has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's words sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 for 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWE
steady course and make sure to check out
our online bookstore at AF bookstore com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at $887 RG
[Music]